good just uh fill in from the back
forward if you would please no problem
hello
so
here
this is dsl
dark sector lab
current home of bicep three and uh this
is the uh spt 10 meter south pole
telescope actually observing
so today is actually a really beautiful
day we're walking back towards the
station here's the tour of the horizon
over there
the
ceremonial south pole
a little bit further over there
the actual south pole
the station
carrot
a very famous
south pole marker
uh
satellite dish over there
the ski way
over here
going towards
the dark sector
the ice cube laboratory
spt south pole telescope 10 meter
telescope
bicep dsl there
mapo
and nothingness
pretty cool
go take a look at the window
on the lee side of the station you'll
see how windy it is
pretty low visibility there's a lot of
snow being blown in the air has turned a
little bit worse than it was yesterday
and the day before
and it turns out south pole has a
running scroll of a bunch of useful
information including the weather in the
south pole so you can just log on onto
the local intranet which you can
actually access
and take a look at a page like this
although it's pretty cold minus 30
it is quite windy 23 knots that's a
little over 40 kilometers an hour that's
quite windy for the south pole so it's a
little bit like blizzard conditions so
in addition to the weather you have a
list of the flights these are the
flights that actually should have
arrived today but because of whether
they were canceled as well as the
satellite passes this is the time and
the three satellites that we communicate
with uh right now we should be able to
use goes but because it's in orange it
actually just means that it's
useless we actually can't get to the
internet or the outside world
items
if you're like me and fascinated by
antarctica and all things scientific you
might want to learn even more at the
great courses plus who've supported this
video they have a whole course filled
with films about polar exploration from
the science of antarctica photography at
the poles and even life among penguins
you could watch about 10 and a half
hours of amazing videos about antarctica
right now or thousands of hours on
pretty much anything else you can think
of all presented by real experts in the
field no more warm tropical climates
with jungles and swamps the last 35
million years have been all about ice no
matter what you're into the great
courses plus is gonna have you covered
and at the moment they're giving you a
month-long free trial to all the videos
all their courses so why not check them
out use the address the great courses
plus dot com slash 60 symbols to get
started there's the link on the screen
or you can use the one i've put in the
video description and our thanks to the
great courses plus for supporting this
video